perché snack abbiamo qui ma è un mio
amico Hahaha
dai il preside con la navicella
scappa dalla scuola Oggi come si pesca
il Brum guardate qua c'è il preside
della scuola bacia un punto di domanda è
tipo in ombra Dobbiamo scoprire ancora
chi è questo presidente della scuola
cattivo in questa nuova Escape Room
della scuola appunto dobbiamo scappare
dal preside quindi non più dal maestro
Luca il professore ma dal preside questa
volta lasciate un bel mi piace mi piace
mi porterà fortuna a scuola Mettetevi
comodi prendete i Popcorn iniziamo
subito
ci siamo tutti e due Qualcuno sta
dormendo ehm
sarà quello il principe a dormire
c'aveva due panini davanti e si mette a
dormire Vitale non avrebbe dormito No
Parla con l'insegnante di detenzione
presto c'è il tempo c'è il tempo Aspetta
aspetta prima disegnate di attenzione
qui è arrabbiato sono stato seduto qui
per quattro ore ora non mi interessa
discutere con il preside ma lasciami
dormire
ok
normale Lascia stare si mette a dormire
in classe mentre ci siamo noi mentre ci
sono i panini
Wow completa la fase 1
Uh questo gioco sembra fatto molto bene
ma ci sono tipo delle trappole Qui sì
non farti mangiare dalle trappole
proviamoci Abbiamo solo un minuto per
evitare le trappole sono sicura che
fosse uno dei miei giochi in cui se
muori devi pagare robox quindi Stai
molto attento capito
Eh ok Allora può essere che ce la farò
anche io piano piano piano
Uh uh ce l'ho fatta Ehi aspetta Dove sei
andato salta sulle palle
per raggiungere l'ufficio salta sulle
pozzanghere No in realtà era evita le
pozzanghere bene Vitale sfracellato in
una bottiglia le posso andare si stanno
espandendo visto
corri corri corri corri corri palla
cambio tutto scappa devo andare qua e il
preside questo oh oh Credo di sì Bene
bene che snack abbiamo qui ma è un mio
amico hahaha
e mangiare in
che vogliono lasciare la punizione e
vengono fatti a fette vengono messi nei
panini e poi vengono no no no no no
mangiati dal preside Okay andiamo avanti
dobbiamo costruire la pila di compiti in
giro per la stanza Ok costruiamo la pila
di compiti ma hai costruito la pila di
compiti
sto costruendo adesso vedete Questi sono
tutti i compiti ma mettendo i compiti
qua un compito diverso Allora io devo
fare delle cose di chimica Ah quindi
Ogni studente ha un compito diverso devo
prendere la carta igienica più il libro
blu più un liquido verde e un'altra cosa
che non so di che colore è ma è una cosa
strana la carta igienica Io sto facendo
i compiti chimici Io sto facendo i
compiti di chimica hai capito che devi
prendere la carta igienica perché questo
richiede la ricetta è cagato addosso
dai Katia
Allora il libro blu dove li proviamo
allora devo dire che sono fortunata a me
sono capitati i compiti scolastici Sì sì
meglio della carta igienica ma ce l'ho
fatta anche d'inverno Non ce l'ho fatta
perché non si apre Aiuto aiuto eh
ah devo premere il pulsante Rosso adesso
ma dove sto andando dove sarà
cerchiamolo tu hai recuperato la carta
igienica
devi andare in bagno no sono chiuso qua
dentro Ah certo era qua il libro il
libro il pulsante rosso come al solito
non vederlo Allora ho trovato la carta
igienica grande Vai portala subito al
preside Tu mi raccomando finisci tutto
il compito Sono il preside ti mangerà mi
hanno chiamato la carta igienica qui
come rotolare Hahaha
Ehi Aspetta un momento che cosa credo
che devo fare anch'io il compito di
chimica adesso
cioè tu sei riuscito a saltare uno dei
compiti
fa Devo trovare la carta igienica Guarda
qui la carta igienica vedi Ce l'ho in
mano è qui Oh ciao sono io Niente
invisibile
Aspetta Ora ho preso la pozione gialla
andiamo
Come no non ti serve ho detto ah devo
prendere quella bianca
in realtà devi darla al preside ti ho
detto
Aspetta non sto capendo dove devo andare
ho messo la carta igienica Forse ho
capito adesso devo prendere il libro blu
seguiamo la formula Prima devo prendere
la pozione Rossa quindi non devo seguire
quello che dice Vitale che io ho deciso
di prendere la carta igienica sì no no
non mettermi le cose qua dentro lo sto
facendo io Levati questo è il mio
calderone adesso
devo trovare l'estintore adesso colore
verde miscela la ciotola che cosa sto
facendo che me lo fanno in calderone Mi
manca solo il registro Ho fatto una
pozione Boom Bing
Boh ma no non è questa quella che mi
serve Ah hai sbagliato Abbiamo sbagliato
pozione hai sbagliato gli ingredienti
probabilmente
oh oh Devo trovare la nostra etichetta
per fare il cretino Mi avete detto
mancante allora nel microonde che cosa
abbiamo bisogno nel microonde vedete
che è il libro blu No l'ho già trovato
l'ho già fatto
dove Dov'è guarda vieni qua Ok dove c'è
la carta igienica Ah ecco
ok mettiamo il libro blu e ora vediamo
che cosa manca cosa manca qui ho una
pozione Rosa bellissima
devo metterla nel microonde
ho bisogno di diamo Allora carta
igienica libro Eh certo il microonde ha
fatto un buco là sotto ma ma come hai
fatto Ah ho seguito le istruzioni della
pozione no le istruzioni sono queste
vedi carta igienica libro blu pozione
verde è uguale solo diverse dalle mie io
vedo un'altra cosa nella lavagna quindi
io ho bisogno di quello
cattivo Cioè ho capito ho capito ho
capito ho capito ho capito ho capito e
quindi quella com'è com'è com'è
Attenzione C'è il preside che si sta non
lo so se dovevamo lascia forza forza Che
schifo come hai fatto Anita Devo trovare
una chiave per scappare dal preside da
evitare Sbrigati a fare la [ __ ]
come hai fatto ad arrivare lì Ho fatto
la pozione giusta Eh ho fatto scoppiare
il microonde che ha aperto un sacco di
gente Ho capito però non avevo capito
[Musica]
Sì Vitale Finalmente è riuscito a
completare la sua pozione che è
impossibile
Eccola l'ho trovata È qua al centro qua
dove sto io però non so cos'è forse per
te sarà in un altro punto Non lo so non
l'ho trovata Comunque guarda qua c'è il
professore non so sta facendo la doccia
ma che cosa e andiamo via subito da qua
dai l'hai trovata questa chiave spiegati
No non l'ho trovata prima che si è
accordati siamo qua posiziona 8 cavi di
alimentazione correttamente
alimentazione
devo dire che è fatta molto bene L'hanno
creata son tante cose originali diverse
e alla fine del video scrivete il vostro
voto da 1 a 10 Anche noi vi darò tre
volte da 1 a 10 Togliti ti sei messa
Davanti mentre Sto eseguendo le mie
riparazioni da elettricista
battere l'elettricista Vitale Guarda che
mi trasforma in preside adesso no no no
no no Ho un'idea lasciate un mi piace
qua sotto avete schiacciato Eh se questo
video raggiunge i 5000 mi piace comprerò
questo questo coso e mi trasformerò in
preside e seguirò Vitale
palestra Wow È troppo figo ci sono
questi qua Questi materassini che ti
permettono di saltare bellissimo eh
materasso elastico Eh mi sono
sfracellato attenta quando è troppo in
alto
Vitale in testa ma tanto amore
[Applauso]
sei tu in testa adesso perché io non
muoio cioè ogni tanto
credo che dobbiamo salire qua adesso ho
capito come fare Wow Chissà se alla fine
dovremmo affrontare il presidente
no
altri laser Allora questi si muovono no
È facilissimo dai Sì devo dire che
finora Io mi sono sfracellata solo una
volta forse sto diventando più bravo
forse l'escape Room che è più facile No
4 5 6 volt
dobbiamo chiamare l'ascensore ascensore
entra no Ehi Ah sei passato dalla porta
chiusa
si è rotto cosa è successo l'ascensore
bloccato come posso uscire da qui non lo
so una delle mie paure più grandi è che
sali sull'ascensore e l'ascensore
precipita E si rompe oppure rimane
bloccato talmente tanto da non poter più
mangiare dici No adesso che cosa mi
mangio nell'ascensore che è bloccato
mentre aspetto Ah dici si sta a dire qua
sopra tu presto Sbrigati prima che cada
tutto come hai fatto a salire là sopra
c'è una corda vedi no no non è caduta
giù devi premere il pulsante SOS
[Applauso]
non cadere Giusto lo devi rifare tutto
da capo Eh Stiamo salendo sempre più in
alto Ma certo che questa scuola è un po'
strana sembra tipo un grattacielo
l'ascensore all'interno troppo grande
per essere una scuola poi scopriremo che
in realtà si nasconde qualche altro in
questa scuola ci posso credere all'idea
tantissimo
sfracellato pochissime volte in questo
Escape Room Infatti qualcosa mi dice che
vincerò io forse questa volta sono nel
corridoio della scuola è tutto buio e
devo saltare
i laser è un trucchetto è un tranello in
realtà è evita i laser non salta soldi
mi hai distratto e mi hai fatto
sfracellare dove sarai imprenditore
No non si è visto il preside però è
tutto buio quindi potrebbe comparire la
chiave qui nella caffetteria l'ho
trovata L'ho trovata No no non è vero
c'è scritto quindi dobbiamo cercare qui
vieni vieni vieni Anita l'ho trovata Sì
è illuminata vai vai vai vai vai non hai
controllato se c'è cibo nella
caffetteria il buio non vedevo niente
Allora che cosa dice qui sembra sia
andato tutto si sia allagato tutto
dobbiamo prendere 6 6 cose arancioni qua
si arancio No la pizza capello dobbiamo
premere tutti i pulsanti Quindi sei ne
dobbiamo premere vediamo che cibo c'è eh
quanti bussato hai premuto tu tre però
adesso mi sono sfracellato quindi
imprenditore Non lo so Non le ho contate
comunque contati aspetta me ne manca uno
due due
ah ah ciao ciao ciao
Evviva Siamo riusciti dove dobbiamo
andare forse Qui c'è una corda qui
guarda dalla coppa dalla coppa della
cucina
italiana
facendo una missione Mission Impossible
Uh dove siamo andati possiamo
Attraversare le scorie tossiche quindi
non toccare la parte verde Ok
come non detto te l'avevo appena detto
comunque questa scuola è gigante è fatta
benissimo Wow voglio esplorarla tutta
sta riuscendo a passare sì devi fare
piano piano
non toccare non sfiorare nemmeno quelle
parti Verdi c'è un quadro del preside
Wow però il quadro si muove ma
è lui non è un quadro è lui ma è dentro
un quadro magari era uno schermo pensi
di poterti nascondere
credo tutto il giorno
quindi ci sta guardando finestra sono le
camere da qualche parte le videocamere
forse dobbiamo continuare da questa
parte dico Vieni qui si fa sempre più
stretto Sì sì sì è qui che dobbiamo
andare Salviamo e ora accettano cadere
su queste assi sotto c'è qualcosa che le
scuole radioattive si scioglie
[Musica]
buttato qua che figo con i magazzini Qui
c'è un qualcosa di elettrico posizione
la scala nel posto giusto e premi il
bottone rosso
eccola qui raccogli la scala
presa Mettiamola qua dove beh qua per
salire qua sopra però prima bisogna
prendere il bottone rosso
premiamo il bottone e via allora
ho paura di perdermi qui No sono qua già
Guarda qua c'è la mappa del labirinto
Allora dobbiamo andare dritti poi a
sinistra poi dritti e poi a sinistra Ok
dritto
e seconda a sinistra
ehi forse seguendo questi passi è ancora
più facile Mi sto per aspetta poi era
dritto in modo che parte qua vero Aiuto
totale dove sei
Ma non mi hai seguito no E allora avete
giocato niente devi seguire i passi
verdi per terra Ah Ah ora ho capito Sì
così è più facile
poi non era la prima ma alla seconda
giusto Sì poi tutto dritto e poi qua
Salviamo Ma tu hai eseguito i passi
Verdi sempre sempre
e sono arrivata qua nel bagno della
scuola ok qui Ops che è successo sei
stata affettata I laser i miei nemici
numero uno sono riuscito Sono passato
sono passato sono passato sono affettato
e qua mi dice di andare sia da quella
parte con le frecce sia qua nel
gabinetto
Cerca raccogli cosa ho trovato
i punti esclamativi ho preso un martello
un martello
Allora bisogna rompere il gabinetto
quello in quello centrale troverà il
martello Sì l'ho preso brava che bello
rompiamo il gabinetto è divertente
questa cosa mi rompe il caminetto
e via siamo nei sotterranei nuovo di
nuovo una radiazioni Qui le cose
tossiche Sì Ma da che parte dovremmo
andare guarda quante Entrate ci sono
Forse dobbiamo entrare in ognuno di
questi Io scelgo questa io provo con
questa Io odio i laser Oddio però
illuminano altrimenti sarebbe stato
tutto al buio Sì ma oltre a illuminare
sfracellano Ah dobbiamo farle tutte
perché ci sono aspetta prima
perché tutti buttati ci sono dei
pulsanti No non avevo capito però credo
che se ti sfracelli devi rifare tutto da
capo quindi cerca di non sfracellarti Ok
secondo pulsante premuto me ne mancano
solo due te Come Ah sì anche io pensavo
fossero 6 Sì sì ok Anch'io l'ho bevuto
due ho deciso di andare sempre in senso
orario così almeno mi ricorderò quali
sono quelli che ho premuto e quelli che
non ho premuto non c'era bisogno perché
tanto si vede quali sono quelli rossi e
quelli verdi è vero Me ne sono appena
accorto
cosa succede Adesso
si è aperto il passaggio
Dobbiamo saltare su questi su questi
pulsantoni giganti grigi siamo ancora
nelle fogne tipo tossiche radioattive
quando rincontreremo il preside cattivo
secondo me lui ci sta ancora guardando
camere
Dobbiamo saltare qua sotto no
No dovevi saltare in questo mi sa
Evviva ho parlato Anita e ora mi
arrampico qua e vado al prossimo video
Siamo siamo in prigione come ha fatto a
prenderci Ma non eravamo riusciti a
scappare c'è anche un gabinetto qua
perché gioca a Akinator
No ma forse il riso e scegli la blocca
Clicca Stop per posizionare la parte
sulla linea rossa Apri la serratura
della porta della prigione Ah ho capito
devo premere stop quando passa nella
linea rossa
Ingrandisci Sì ce l'ho fatta sono stata
velocissima e ora vado
prima
della prigione Sì sì indietro Dai presi
dai con la navicella tipo come mai sei
sopravvissuta alle mie e perché lui
siamo fortissimi Beh sono un po' a
sorpresa lì lì Ma che importa Questa è
la tua fine vedremo Tra l'altro Guarda
c'abbiamo qua zucca Guarda
bazooka Attento attento perché lui pure
ci spara Oh no Qualcosa mi dice che sarà
molto difficile
il bazooka deve ricaricarsi hai vinto ci
mette un sacco Eccolo qua spariamo aerei
di carta
è fatta super bene questo Escape Room
super carina ma dov'è la sua vita eh non
lo sai che non lo vedo il presidente è
su in alto è su in alto lo vedi rosso ma
allora mi manca solo un colpo l'ho preso
attento Eh aspetta Ma dov'è la mia vita
ce l'hai fatta sì sì sì sì dai dai dai
dai
di nuovo Adesso sarà più difficile Vedi
ha più vita e in effetti mi sembrava
troppo facile prenderlo
sta sparando 3-4 missili alla volta è
incredibile Sì infatti è troppo
difficile adesso aiuto perché si
ricarica così devo scappare in
continuazione Ecco abbiamo ripreso
ci sei riuscito
mi mancano due cose
aiuto aiuto aiuto
Aspetta che colpisce lo colpisce
ora diventerò ancora più difficile o ce
la faremo ma credo di sì perché dice
questo è ridicolo metterò fine a tutto
questo proprio
Anna beccarlo anche dentro dice il
presidente Furioso
attento Non capitare nei cerchi rotti
anche questi si beccherà con i tuoi il
codice destinati
e poi bisogna aspettare che si ricarichi
bazooka
mi mancano due colpi dai posso farcela
tu invece a che punto sei Ho dovuto
ricominciare perché mi ha colpito No
dai puoi farcela Stai zitto ci provo
non l'ho beccato mi manca un colpo dai
preside Beccati questo
che succede è diventato tutto bianco
sei riuscita
no mi sta prendendo Oh mi manca solo
colpa ma non ce la faccio dai io ce l'ho
fatta Ti aspetto Forse ce l'ho fatta
Ecco Vitale che corre invisibile ci sei
riuscito prendi la chiave adesso a
raccoglier Eccolo qua
e adesso vediamo
apriamo questa porta
c'è scritto
Speriamo davvero che ti sia piaciuto il
gioco perché se siamo divertiti molto
Abbiamo passato molto tempo a lavorarci
per favore lascia un mi piace hai
sbloccato modalità difficile
abbiamo conquistato anche questo badge
come voto io gli do un 9 gli avrei dato
un punto in più se fosse durata di più
questo tipo per me è stata un po' Veloce
però comunque è bellissima Tu che voto
gli dai peggio per me però il presidente
era troppo divertente mi piaceva ah ah
la so come mi piace però vi lasciamo Qua
quattro caselline su cui cliccare per
vedere i nostri altri video cliccate su
quella che preferite eh Buona visione
Ciao